If there’s anything that recent years have sadly
taught us, it’s that diseases are an insidious and
formidable enemy that can take you by surprise.
Whether it’s bacterial, a virus, a fungal
infection, or even an unfortunate genetic mutation
like cancer, Alzheimer’s, or Multiple Sclerosis,
sometimes dealing with a dangerous pathogen
could leave you praying for a run-in with SCP-682
after all, at least getting devoured by
a giant, evil reptile is a quick death.
But take a page out of the SCP Foundation’s
book: Sometimes, the best response to an imminent
threat is containment and research. One of the
first rules of combat is to know your enemy.
It may seem like a tall order to have
to write the book on dangerous diseases,
but thankfully, that book has
already been written: it’s SCP-1025
The Encyclopedia of Common Diseases. This
handy, reader-friendly volume will tell
you everything you need to know about all the
common maladies you may find yourself facing,
and a whole lot more. From the sniffles to lung
cancer, from a cold sore to necrotizing fasciitis.
You may be thinking, “Why would I need some
dusty old book to tell me about diseases?
I can always just go to WebMD.” But you don’t want
that. You know what the internet is like: They’ll
just tell you you’re sick, and you don’t want
them putting silly ideas in your head like that.
How about you open up to a random page and we’ll
take a look. There, see? The Common Cold. Classic.
Let’s see the description: “The Common Cold is a
virus that affects the upper respiratory tract.
Its duration is typically a maximum of two weeks,
and its primary symptoms include headaches, muscle
aches, a cough, a runny nose, raised temperature,
pressure in the ears or face, and a loss of taste
or smell.” See? Simple, straightforward,
and objective. Exactly what you need.
Did you just cough? That’s strange. Hmm, and come
to think of it, your nose is looking a little red.
Do you need a tissue? Or perhaps a throat
lozenge? Your voice seems a little hoarse.
Perhaps you ought to take a break and lay down.
You really don’t look so good. Seems like the
common cold to us. Thankfully, you shouldn’t have
to worry about it for more than two weeks. Oh,
and that reminds me: There is a certain anomalous
effect to the Encyclopedia of Common Diseases.
Whenever you read about a pathogen in
the Encyclopedia of Common Diseases,
you catch it, manifesting even its most severe
symptoms in an extremely brief period of time.
Of course, this isn’t that much of a problem
if you just read the article about having
a sore throat or a stomach bug, but what
if you read the page for Ebola? Suddenly,
you’re half-dead and bleeding from the eyes. Or
the Bubonic Plague? Or a disease that humanity
has never even faced before? And what
if, worst of all, the people who catch
the diseases from this book continue to be
contagious to others? It could be the basis
for a world-destroying biological weapon and at
the very least, a bonafide Keter-Class anomaly.
When the SCP Foundation got their hands on
this little hardcover anomalous nightmare,
the researchers handling this thing realized
it needed to be kept under lock and key.
A new provisional site was created
just to contain and research it
without the risk of its anomalous effects
starting an unstoppable global pandemic.
The base was an isolated underground bunker,
containing an even more high-security containment
unit to store the book itself: A vault surrounded
by at least ten armed guards at any given time,
rotated twice weekly and checked
for any infectious agents.
There was even a powerful thermite bomb
stored beneath the vault, set to go off and
annihilate the entire chamber if the plausible
risk of a containment breach was detected.
It may seem insane to put in this many security
fail-safes for a simple anomalous book, but the
SCP Foundation has dealt with dangerous books
before. Take SCP-140, also known as an Incomplete
Chronicle. This dangerous historical volume
chronicles the living history of the Daevites,
an extinct culture of sadistic sorcerers
closely tied to the mythos of the Scarlet King.
Whenever ink or blood is brought into the
presence of this book, it absorbs the material,
expanding the Daevite’s history and bringing their
terrifying rule ever closer to the modern day.
Or take SCP-3512, “The More You Know: A Pick-Up
Artist’s Bible”, a deadly instruction manual made
by a mind-controlling group of interest known
as the Fifthists. This book gave its sinister
practitioners the tools to control the minds of
their potential romantic partners, often leading
to their deaths. While it may not be quite as
apocalyptic as SCP-1025 or SCP-140, the fact
that there are so many in circulation still makes
it a dangerous threat. Point is, a book can be a
dangerous thing, especially if its pages have the
potential to unlock deadly diseases like SCP-1025.
As you can expect with an infectious Keter-Class
anomaly of this magnitude, procedures around this
one were rigorous. The site staff was a skeleton
crew, observing strict quarantine procedures to
prevent any potential infection from leaking out
into the wider world. Research into the history
of the book was inconclusive, despite a bevy of
Foundation resources being poured into finding
any worthwhile leads on the author or publisher
of the book. Nothing. It was an absolute mystery
who or what had put this XK-Class End of the World
Scenario waiting to happen here on earth. But now,
it was the job of these intrepid researchers to
discover the full extent of its potential dangers.
27 D-Class subjects were
allocated to the base for testing.
By the time the process was over, none of
these unlucky prisoners would remain alive.
The tests started much like this video: The
Researchers forced a D-Class to read the
section on the Common Cold. Within two hours,
the subject began coughing. Upon being asked,
they also reported feeling physically achey,
though they attributed the ache to sleeping on
an uncomfortable D-Class cot every night.
The researchers were concerned already:
The incubation period for the common cold -
meaning the period a person is infected before
showing active symptoms - can be as long
as three days. Two hours is unprecedented.
Next, a D-Class was told to read the section on
Chicken Pox, a common childhood malady that can be
considerably more dangerous in adulthood. Within
an hour of being exposed, the D-Class repeatedly
scratched no less than five points on her body
repeatedly. While she claimed this was because
of the itchy D-Class jumpsuits, it was too eerily
close to a symptom of Chicken Pox to be ignored.
The medical history of this D-Class also showed
that she’d suffered Chicken Pox in childhood,
suggesting that SCP-1025 infections have
the power to override previous immunities.
Next, things got a little more serious:
They tested the section on lung cancer
on a D-Class with no family history
of lung conditions. Not long after,
the researchers noted that the D-Class coughed
an unusual number of times. Not only that, they
picked up irregularities in the D-Class’ breathing
that appeared to be characteristic of lung cancer.
While the D-Class did not report any feelings
of chest pain or discomfort, the researchers
had him terminated and dissected. No tumors were
found. A researcher noted that they didn’t wait
long enough for proper tumor manifestation -
They knew they heard that D-Class coughing.
The researchers were so concerned
by the results of the previous test,
they repeated it exactly with another D-Class,
who they then observed over a period of seven
days to track tumor manifestation. Researchers
made a note of an unusual amount of coughing and
wheezing from the subject over this period
of time. The D-Class was then terminated
and dissected - But surprise, surprise, no tumors.
Researchers began to consider the frightening
possibility that signs of SCP-1025-induced
illness disappear after the victims die,
meaning that a pandemic started by SCP-1025 would
be impossible to properly track and respond to.
Things were only getting scarier and
scarier for the SCP-1025 researchers,
sequestered away in that
isolated Foundation bunker.
Researchers continued to delve further
into the lung cancer rabbit hole:
This time, however, they didn’t wait for the
subject to die before looking at their insides.
They instead performed a vivisection on
the subject, only to find that despite the
victim still being alive and displaying some
of the key symptoms of lung cancer, there were
no tumors. What could this mean? These diseases
weren’t behaving like any of their non-anomalous
counterparts. What other differences could we
be dealing with here? Infectious lung cancer?
And what if there are more books out there,
like time bombs, just waiting to go off?
The tests continued, getting more isolated and
more intense. In the end, the SCP-1025 site was
staffed by only three researchers and two agents
acting as guards. D-Classes were sent in one by
one to minimize ration requirements. It seemed
they could have been dealing with one of the most
dangerous anomalies of all time - even working
with it could be a trigger for the apocalypse,
if the proper containment and
quarantine procedures weren’t observed.
Things got so out of hand that a D-Class
without an appendix was told to read the
section on Appendicitis, and researchers still
observed him exhibiting symptoms of the condition.
He was vivisected, and while the appendix was
still not present, the organs in the area where
the appendix would have been seemed redder
than usual. Where would this nightmare end?
Well, it would actually end much sooner
than anyone involved would anticipate.
Despite never even reading SCP-1025 himself, a
researcher developed a strange persistent cough
and was quarantined in a containment chamber by
his concerned colleagues. On the seventh day of
his confinement, he seemed to be slightly taller
than before - a symptom of SCP-016, a deadly,
anomalous blood-borne pathogen that multiplies
wildly and rewrites the genetic structure of
its host if placed into a high-stress situation.
This led to a number of terrifying revelations:
Not only did the book have the potential
to inflict a number of anomalous diseases,
but it could also potentially do so by pure
proximity, even if you don’t actually read it.
What other anomalous diseases could be on the
table now? What about SCP-008, a terrifying
prion with both 100% virality and 100% lethality?
Or SCP-742, a retrovirus that slowly but surely
transforms its victims into cannibalistic
monsters? Or even the horrifying SCP-217,
the disease that slowly converts your
entire body into a mechanical nightmare?
There would be no limit to the horrors
SCP-1025 could unleash on the world if
ever it got out. They needed to keep
this thing locked up at any cost.
That’s when the infected researcher
escaped, and all hell broke loose.
The isolated facility went dark for 72 hours.
After not being able to get into contact with
any other Foundation bases during that time, a
recovery team was sent to investigate the mystery.
One agent and one researcher were found in the
observation booth, wearing biological containment
suits. Another agent was found crawling
through the air ducts with his handgun drawn,
a crazed look in his eye. An additional researcher
had locked himself in the barracks with a homemade
flamethrower, paranoid about infection.
And the final agent was found dead
in a storage locker with some empty bottles and
ration packages, after having given the door an
airtight seal to prevent infection
- then dying of suffocation inside.
The O5 Council shuttered the entire investigation.
SCP-1025 was downgraded from Keter to Safe Class,
then placed in a storage locker. The
whole thing was considered a wash.
We know what you’re probably wondering: Why!?
If this anomaly was so incredibly dangerous,
why on earth would the O5 Council and the rest
of the Foundation be dealing with it so casually?
Well, that’s simple: The initial batch of
researchers had grievously misjudged the actual
anomalous effect of SCP-1025. It doesn’t give
diseases to those who read its text - instead,
it induces a form of “hypochondria by proxy”
to those around the reader. In other words,
while SCP-1025 has no effect on the reader, it
makes everyone around them merely believe that
they’ve come down with a terrible illness. The
few members of staff in that isolated site had
been killing and dissecting D-Classes for no
reason. In effect, they’d all effectively gone
mad due to the anomalous effects of SCP-1025 and
the paranoia induced by pressure and isolation.
Much like your average hypochondriac, they’d
warped the data to fit the worst possible
outcome rather than the more mundane and
likely. As an old medical expression goes,
“When you see hoofprints, think horses,
not zebras.” The entire thing had been a
terrifying waste of time, money, and human life.
So perhaps, in the end, the Encyclopedia
of Common Diseases is a lot more like WebMD
than we thought. It’s not nearly as useful as
getting a consultation with an actual doctor,
and of course, it’s liable to put some
very strange ideas in your head...
Now go check out “SCP-2852 Sadistic
Madman Party Crasher | Cousin Johnny”
and “SCP-701 - The Hanged King's Tragedy”
for more SCPs that’ll drive you to madness!